قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان انه
يجري مباحثات الاحد المقبل مع رئيس روسيا
واوكرانيا لمعالجه تباطئ عمليات تصدير
الحبوب اضافه اردوغان في كلمته امام منتدى
تي ار تي الدولي ان الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه تسببت في اعباء كبيره للعالم
مشيراني لانه لا منتصره في الحرب ولا خاسر
في السلام وقال ان جهود بلاده ستستمر لحل
الازمه الروسيه الاوكرانيه وازمه الطاقه
منذ اليوم الاول الازمه في اوكرانيا هو
نحن نقول انه لا غالب في الحرب ولا خاسر
في السلام ولهذا بدرنا ومازلنا نبادر
بدبلوماسيه للسلام بين رئيس دولتين ورغم
ما يصدر على انه توقف حدث في مسيره
اسطنبول سنستمر في مساعينا على مستوى
الزعيم الدولتين لان هذه المسيره هي
المنطلق الانسب حتى الان من اجل تاسيس
السلام الدائم بين روسيا واوكرانيا وفيما
يتعلق بتباط بتوريد المواد الحيويه
والهامه للعالم من اوكرانيا وروسيا وعلى
روسيا الحبوب ساتصل يوم الاحد مع السيد
بلادي مير بوتين ومن بعده السيد معالجتها